all right hold up we got a letter here
uh suzanne a trot md fax wait a minute
where'd this come from sam and mark you
guys are
[ __ ] hilarious and we love your
podcast we know you love boobs so we
decided to send you some
these are just demos but they make great
stress balls happy holidays boogie
parker and suzanne trott
holy [ __ ]
we gotta open these fake tits here is
that what it is my lord i can't believe
what i'm seeing
wait a minute
we have an interesting uh
fan base
wait a minute
hold on what is this these are fake
breasts md we just feel these
beverly hills california doctortrot.com
d-r-t-r-o-t-t.com check them out
i'm scared to touch them whoa
they're sealed look at this
wow i'm i'm nervous
holy [ __ ] i can't believe what i'm
seeing here
so this is a fake breast this might be
possible i like that you gave us one
each
yeah you could have given us two well
you know you only need one oh my god
that feels great and these don't pop i
guess right that's the whole thing
oh do they yes this is a nice stress
ball
oh i can feel it yeah
yeah dude
wow and i threw a layer of skin on that
and you're at a titty bar
whoa
these are great i'm taking this home
i'm gonna show the lady and go you see
what you could do
you really applied yourself
this is crazy
i love it that's her that's the doctor
oh god thanks suzanne
trott
you got to be a hot doctor in beverly
hills you can't be uh
can't be gross they won't they won't use
you
they're very shallow out there let me
see that one for a second
[Music]
motorboat
wow that's great this is insane and now
is this silicone saline salt water what
are the how do they do it now remember
david schwimmer and chris cooper when
that would be breast man
dude you're [ __ ] great you know every
every movie i can't tell you who's vice
president but uh
should we
dude
we gotta i wanna i wanna do a patreon we
just literally analyze saved by the bell
clips
oh that would be great i just wanna talk
over saved by the bell yeah
cut
oh yeah you have to go
dude we should pull some of that [ __ ] up
matt cause
pull up a couple say by the belt like
what are the top rated say by the belt
well there's a i'm so excited i'm so
excited she was addicted to no doze
remember that
let's get that [ __ ] on we're really
doubting ourselves this is crazy oh i
can't stop squeezing it
tits are really
uh beloved you know i wish people love
balls as much as they love tits
right there's no fake balls no i guess
there are but no no woman would want to
like hold one no no balls are gross
uh oh